[Musica]
quando sono stata invitata a partecipare
al Ted avevo pensato di raccontare la
serie post occupato che cosa è successo
in questi anni andiamo verso i 10 anni
quanto è stato importante l'impatto dal
punto di vista mediatico di questa
campagna che è stata creata Per
sensibilizzare rispetto al fenomeno
della violenza
avrei parlato della prevenzione di
quanto è necessario fare formazione di
Che cos'è questo posto appunto che
rappresenta le donne che non ci sono più
io vi dico dei nomi e non so se voi vi
ricordate questi nomi ormai Ma
Alessandra Stefania
Lorena che cosa vi dicono Bonina che
cosa vi dicono mi ricordano qualche cosa
ora vi dico pure i cognomi omai la
bengalum Alessandra Musarra Stefania
Gambadoro Stefania ordì Lorena quaranta
e Bonina buttò sono le donne che nella
nostra provincia sono state uccise
vittime di violenza dai loro compagni
delle loro mariti e che purtroppo non ci
sono più perché il femminicidio che
l'ultimo atto estremo i reversibile di
come può essere esercitata la violenza
sulle donne non li ha consentito oggi di
essere qui con noi o qui al mio posto o
con voi nel pubblico come c'è il posto
occupato in prima fila e queste posso
occupato la storia e racconto sempre
appunto che è legata all'iniziativa in
realtà cade il 15 aprile che per me è un
giorno molto importante il 15 aprile del
giorno che è morto mio padre 10 anni fa
esattamente che coincidono con i dieci
anni di post occupato ragionando sulle
origini post occupato ho detto Vabbè
diciamo un altro pezzo della storia
perché qui si raccontano le storie
e gli speaker vengono invitati per
raccontare le storie delle loro
esperienze e allora ho pensato di essere
nel posto giusto con una platea
qualificata Qual è quella che partecipa
per poter raccontare un altro pezzetto
di questa storia perché la storia nasce
appunto da delle crepe il mio chinzucho
la mia arte di riparare le crepe alcune
delle creme della mia vita
sono state riparate con questo Filo
d'Oro che me l'ha consentito fosse
occupato di farlo perché per me è stato
un modo dopo vent'anni in una prima
parte di
un evento che mi era caduto di silenzio
dopo due anni di un altro evento che mi
era accaduto che invece del silenzio
c'era stata la denuncia c'era stata
l'aiuto c'era stato il supporto io ho
dovuto trovare una modalità per provare
ad aiutare anche le altre donne che
erano state meno fortunate di me che
sono appunto le donne vittime di
femminicidio In modo tale da poter
essere su questo palco e poter
raccontare i loro storie Ecco perché è
nata post occupato perché io pensavo
sempre che quando sentivo le notizie in
televisione dicevo sempre potevo esserci
io in quel posto e quindi avevo
necessità bisogno urgenza di creare
qualche cosa che potesse essere utile a
tutte le altre donne a tutte le altre
mamme i figli e sorelle a tutti gli
altri uomini perché come dico sempre io
la campagna postulata non è contro gli
uomini la campagna questo cuore è contro
la violenza
perché la violenza non è un'emergenza
come spesso ci dicono i giornali è un
profondissimo problema culturale che
abbiamo noi in Italia che siamo un paese
che ci diciamo evoluto che sia un paese
sviluppato ma che in realtà
conviviamo con questo fenomeno che vede
moltissime donne
moltissime persone fragili vittime di
violenza ogni giorno ma soprattutto post
occupato doveva rappresentare quello che
significa quando queste donne viene
negato di essere accanto a noi lavorare
con noi vivere con noi gioire con noi
viaggiare con noi ma far carico alla
società di questo problema Il problema
culturale doveva diventare anche una
responsabilità sociale Ecco perché posso
occupato è diventata questa campagna
virale si è manifestata in pochissimo
tempo si parlava di contagio perché
prima post occupato è stato occupato a
Rometta che il paese nel quale Io sono
residente e che ho sentito volerla
creare proprio al paese di Rometta
perché la statistica io dico sempre la
statistica dice che una donna su tre
vittime di violenza per cui sul nostro
pianerottolo ci sarà una vittima di
violenza Ecco su quel pianerottolo in
questo caso c'ero io ecco perché oggi
aggiungo un altro pezzettino di quello
che l'origine posso occupato perché non
avevo ancora raccontato pubblicamente
questa storia e l'avevo solo lasciata
chiusa all'interno di una ristrettissima
cerchia di persone a me molto vicine di
parente di amici quindi
la professoressa Cocchiara che è una
persona che ha molto amato che sapeva
questa storia e sa esattamente che cosa
è successo la prima e la seconda volta
che mi vide protagonista di
un percorso diciamo legato a fatti non
molto felici mi diceva hai fatto una
cosa straordinaria con un post occupato
una campagna che ha una forza e un
efficace una potenza straordinaria Ma
devi fare altro le devi raccontare
queste cose e quindi mi fece promettere
in volo perché stavamo tornando da un
viaggio con lei in Sardegna di scrivere
un libro e io dovevo essere pronta ad
scrivere questo libro Sono passati tanti
anni come non ero pronta di raccontare
che il posto occupato alla fine nasce da
quello che era diciamo un problema che
io avevo che io ero riuscita a sanare a
riparare Che Come dico come dicono gli
orientali con Kiki
e allora probabilmente c'è la necessità
di fare il passaggio successivo quindi
oggi
questi dieci anni di vostro padre in
realtà partono da molto prima partono da
30 anni fa e partono da 14 anni fa 14
anni fa quando
io con l'aiuto delle forze dell'ordine
della magistratura del mio avvocato che
non smetterò mai di ringraziare sono
stata
[Musica]
salvata da quello che poteva essere un
percorso che avrebbe portato
probabilmente a uno di questi episodi
che noi avremmo letto sui giornali e
Leggendo sui giornali noi Poi ce li
dimentichiamo i nomi di quelle persone
ci dimentichiamo che cosa facevano ci
dimentichiamo di che cosa erano nella
vita delle loro famiglie e della nostra
società Ecco perché questa necessità di
fare qualche cosa ma perché non è
partito
subito dopo l'evento che mi era accaduto
E io aspetto altri quattro anni prima di
lanciare post occupato e legata alla
data della perdita di mio padre perché
se mio padre fosse stato in vita Io non
avrei fatto pubblicamente niente che
potesse avere a che fare con un impegno
pubblico rispetto al contesto alla
violenza perché per me era necessario
che mio padre avesse una serenità che
probabilmente sapere che io ero
impegnata in una tematica del genere gli
avrebbe fatto sospettare che potevo
essere coinvolta in qualche modo per cui
per amore di mio padre io non avevo mai
voluto in qualche modo smuovere niente
per poterlo stare tranquillo sereno è
felice come lui pensava che io fossi
perché è sempre pensato che fossi un
supereroe ma non ipotesi Io sono stata
molto fragili ho avuto molte crepe e li
ho molto riparate negli anni mi sono
ritrovata a confrontarmi con questo
mondo della violenza personalmente
direttamente e indirettamente attraverso
la campagna ha avuto modo di conoscere e
incontrare altrettante persone
straordinarie Probabilmente uno degli
incontri che mi ha ancora di più
fortificato è stato l'incontro con
Franca Viola nel 2012 questo sempre
prima di lanciare la campagna post
occupato perché Francavilla veramente
era una donna straordinaria Lei sì che
nel 1965 ha dovuto confrontarsi e
affrontare in un momento che sicuramente
non era quello che viviamo noi oggi di
come è molto più comune per la violenza
sulle donne parlare di stupri parlare di
abusi lei era veramente sola ed era solo
in un territorio che era quello di
Alcamo dove assieme alla violenza quella
che normalmente viene agita sulle donne
e c'era pure il fenomeno mafioso
potentissimo tant'è che il suo fidanzato
era pure mafioso e lei ebbe il coraggio
di denunciarlo nel 1965 quando io non
era ancora nata Ecco perché ci tengo
anche a precisare Quanto è importante la
figura di Franca Viola rispetto a quello
che il percorso che io ho fatto per
arrivare al posto occupato e tutto
quello che poi viene conseguito
ci sono dei semi che in questi anni sono
stati
piantati con post occupato andare nelle
scuole e incontrare altre donne ritiene
di violenza
Ascoltare le loro storie Ci sono tre fra
le centinaia di storie che mi sono
capitate di vivere o comunque di
ascoltare Ce ne sono tre che mi hanno
molto colpito una è i primissimi anni
arrivò una media di un uomo che si
trovava a teatro un signore che stiamo
parlando del 2013 quando ancora di
femminicidi e violenza sulle donne se ne
parlava veramente poco si parlava
pochissimo del 15 22 si parlava
pochissimo la convenzione di Istanbul
per cui questo signore andando a teatro
si sedette fra il primo e il secondo
atto si accorse che accanto alla sua
poltrona non si era seduto nessuno e gli
sembrava una cosa strana perché erano
uno spettacolo molto importante
famoso e quindi non c'era nessuno si
avvicinò a quella poltrona e l'esse che
c'era la locandina di post occupato e
capi questa cosa era rivolta quella
locandina e quanto era stato per lui
d'impatto capire che c'era stata nella
società Appunto una donna che era stata
privata della vita della persona che
l'avrebbe invece dovuta se non
proteggere quanto meno amare quanto meno
rispettare e non era più potuto andare a
teatro non era lì a vedersi lo
spettacolo con lui e questa cosa l'ho
colpita talmente che scrisse questa mail
appunto a posto occupato dicendo che lui
da quel giorno non dimenticò mai più che
cosa significa non essere attenti a
quello che succede accanto a noi perché
probabilmente lui era una di quelle
persone che se sentivo urlare
l'appartamento accanto al suo non si
sarebbe preoccupato più di tanto perché
erano fatti magari dei vicini di casa
piuttosto che fermarsi a intervenire se
vedeva una lite di qualcuno per strada o
quello che accade comunemente a tutti
noi e ringraziò la campagna Per avergli
aperto questo mondo rispetto a quello
che può produrre la violenza quando
viene
sottovalutata o quando si è indifferente
al fenomeno perché appunto deve essere
una responsabilità sociale quella di
occuparci del fenomeno della violenza
un altro episodio è quello di una
signora che
si firmava si è firmata Ma la chiameremo
Nunzia questa Nunzia scriveva era
proprio una confessione che la sua vita
era stata rovinata da una leva una
ultrasettantenne quasi ottantenne
raccontava con questa scrittura che
faceva capire quanto era
tremante il suo momento quanto era
dedicato a questo momento di confessione
appunto che lei per tutta la vita era
stata maltrattata picchiata violata E
abusata da questo marito che aveva
sposato quando lui aveva 16 anni era
rimasta incinta e quindi non poteva fare
altro che tenersi Questo marito perché
comunque era quello che l'aveva sposata
essendo il padre di suo figlio
ha confessato Senza
indugio e la sua
serenità rispetto al fatto che un giorno
i vigili andavano a casa sua dicendole
che quest'uomo era morto perché era pure
un delinquente che entrava e usciva dal
carcere e appunto un giorno che
quest'uomo fu trovato morto perché era
anche un tossicodipendente
è alcolizzato e lei si Senti Serena e
non era dispiaciuta lo diceva con una
crudezza lo scriveva Scusate perché l'ho
letto dalla sua lettera lo spiega con
una crudezza che mi aveva fatto capire
quanto dolore aveva questa donna ma
quanto sollievo gli aveva dato la morte
di questa persona quella quale lei mi
invita non si era mai riuscita a
liberare perché evidentemente era sola
perché purtroppo un'altra cosa che
spesso non si fanno dare che la violenza
va a braccetto con la solitudine le
donne che sono vittime di violenza se
sono sole
saranno ancora più deboli saranno ancora
più fragili saranno ancora più
condannate a morte da loro aguzzini ecco
perché la responsabilità sociale e tutti
ci dobbiamo fare carico
l'ultima cosa che vi voglio raccontare è
proprio dei semi e in una delle
iniziative che si chiamava Franca e le
altre in giro per tutta la Sicilia con
un camper in una scuola in una scuola
abbiamo somministrato un miliardo di
questionari in giro per tutte le scuole
in una delle scuole un questionario che
abbiamo raccolto una delle domande era
Conoscete il 15 22
il questionario noi lo diciamo di
compilarlo alla fine dell'intervento che
facevamo io essere una Majorana che era
la mia amica con la quale abbiamo
portato avanti questa iniziativa
alla voce Conoscete il 15 22 hanno
barato Sì e poi accanto hanno scritto
noi prima non lo conoscevamo Grazie a
voi adesso sì e hanno disegnato un
fiorellino Ecco questa cosa Se posso
dare come dire un valore un premio a
quello che la campagna mi ha portato è
quel fiorellino di questi ragazzi che
hanno scritto che grazie a noi adesso
sapevano che cos'è il 15 22 e che
probabilmente sapendo quel numero sanno
che possono aggiungere sia loro e
aiutate in caso di bisogno ma anche loro
essere in grado di aiutare Qualche altro
che ha bisogno Ecco che cos'è post
occupato a che cosa vuole fare vuole
fare sensibilizzazione vuole fare
prevenzione e informazione e soprattutto
quello che mi auguro per i prossimi 10
anni e che questa locandina con questo
posto non ci sia mai più e che impariamo
tutti a rispettare l'altro e che fra
dieci anni ormai ma piuttosto che Lorena
vengono sul palco a raccontare la loro
storia della loro diritto di essere vive
libere Piuttosto che essere state
vittime di violenza come nel caso di cui
abbiamo parlato Grazie
[Applauso]